could not be more thrilled to welcome to
our home our first in-studio guest in
well over a calendar year and he is
somebody i could not be more fond of
um i i love this man my wife loves this
man potentially more than me but that's
fine
it's all good he is the host of first
take and stephen a's world on espn plus
stephen a smith
my brother here in person how you doing
my man it's good to see you good to see
you
you know well we can't start off
anything how's the wife how's the world
she
is doing very well that's my girl right
now i know
that and she she wanted me to send my
best to you
uh you're always so kind of calling when
she she's you're one of her go-to
uh guests when she sits in this chair
which means a lot to me when she does
of course and so it is great to see her
yeah man it's good to see you too how
you doing i am doing well you are uh
you're one of the busiest men
in this business so stephen a's world
let's get right into that
uh weeknights yeah uh every week four
nights a week except this one which is
kind enough for you to be here
on on your day off of that why why
stephen a's world
well listen i you know when you do a
debate show for as long as we've been
doing it i've been blessed and fortunate
to be doing first date since 2012.
and you know uh to host my own show to
do interviews and things of that nature
to sort of bring a
bit of lead to the situation in terms of
just having a good time
you know getting back to what i do
journalistically interviewing folks
talking to them
particularly when you connect not just
the sports world but the pop culture
world as well that was a big thing
just stepping away from the debate
format to some degree yeah even though i
did that with radios too but
the other thing is i'm the executive
producer of the show and i've got my own
production company mr sas productions
which co-produces the show along with
espn and that's something that i'm
looking to venture into
i want to do docu series i want to do
scripted and non-scripted
um content as well it's something that
i've aspired to do for a very very long
time and so the opportunity
to have my own show under the espn
banner
and you know streaming is the way to go
in this day and age as well
oh yeah it just all made perfect sense
and that's why i was so excited to do it
you and i were talking on a streamer
yeah
that's right so and there's a lot of
people in our business who are like
streamer
well you know i mean so but i i don't
feel that way you know
when you were doing the great job that
you've always been doing television over
all of these years i was still doing
newspapers
and so you know just moving the radio
and moving the television a lot
of people in the newspaper industry
didn't see it you know they
they didn't see the advent of you know
dot-com coming in the fold and what have
you and you know
that the newspaper business in terms of
you know broad sheet or tabloids and
you know even though it exists online in
terms of
subscribers it was going to diminish and
you had to see it coming and i saw it
coming and so
making that move and i look at streaming
in a similar fashion where
you know the content is king but the man
in which it's disseminated
varies it changes it's amazing stephen a
because
um there are probably a lot of people in
this world
who emulate you emulate what you have
become
and don't know the written word was the
first thing
for you do you miss writing do you miss
the written word
i miss it to some degree um in terms of
you know
but i love potency i love i love power
from the standpoint of
you know who are you reaching does it
really really resonate and the fact that
you know what i can write what i would
write 800 words
or a thousand words as a columnist okay
well i go on the air and i i spew a
thousand words out of my mouth in five
minutes
so it's like wait a minute i mean you
know you could you could say a lot more
yes
you could get a multitude of messages
out there but
but newspaper is the foundation what you
learn journalistically
the integrity that comes along with it
you know yeah i mean obviously when
you're debating and stuff like that
people see the hot takes and stuff like
that and
you know why did they say this or why
did they say that but i pride myself on
being a human being first so
i might call you out for what you do yes
but i'm not going to character
assassinate you and try to define who
you are and things of that nature
and i remember one time somebody came up
to me and they said you know stephen
abwell
damn it if you know this is going to
happen why did you have to say this
and i looked at them and i said do you
watch soap operas and they were like no
not really listen let me tell you
something about soap operas
i don't know if you watch young and the
restless on cbs i said
but there's a guy by the name of eric
braden who plays the role of victor
newman
i said i i'm a general hospital fan
there's a guy by the name of maurice
bernard who plays sonny corinthos
i said did you know that they're going
to live no matter what did you know
they can get shot they can get stabbed
they can fall down a flight of stairs
they can they can fall off a bridge
dammit they can get in the plane crew it
doesn't matter they're going to live
it doesn't stop the soaps from telling
the story
that's what we do we tell a story now
for example don't you know the cowboys
think you know they're not going to win
right they're not going to win i said
but
you have to chronicle what they're doing
now listen michael irvin don't you know
he's going to be sad that he's going to
disappear for a couple of weeks when the
season's over he's
like a center apb out for him because he
can't be found because the dallas
cowboys stunk up the joint
just like we said but it doesn't stop
him
from coming on the air every sunday
morning with one of those zoot suits on
proclaiming that the cowboys are going
to be relevant
you know you still gotta tell the story
and that's what i try to do that's what
i try to remind people
sometimes they listen sometimes they
don't i understand that stephen a and i
got to tell you
uh sitting on the set of nfl game day
morning i have a lot of great times with
my with my colleagues
it's always great when a producer gets
in my ear right it says steven ages
tweeted it
yes and i'm like okay this is going to
be great
yeah you seem to really relish tweeting
at michael irvin
and and relish i mean and then his
appearance on first take where he
he needed a towel to basically wipe his
brow
i will tell you this yes that appearance
he made on first take
when he needed the time when you talk
about he needed the tower to wipe
himself yeah
we were in uh we were in dallas texas we
were right by
a t stadium um it was the greatest
time i've ever had in the history of
first day it's that without question
i mean it was three levels to the
restaurant it was
packed to the house i mean it was barely
standing room it wasn't a seat in the
house
and that audience being there and then
michael irvin said
we don't just tell your story tell these
stories
and it's screaming i have taken over
his show and the entire crowd is
chanting
my goal i'm like this is hilarious you
know
and i'm loving it a because it's great
television b
because i love having him on the show
because he's my buddy and i love him
like a brother
but c i know the inevitable
and what gets lost in all of that is
they were playing the tennessee titans
that night
because it was a monday right and they
were playing the tennessee titans on
monday night football i said they're
gonna lose a night
and sure enough they lost sure enough
they lost i mean
they just snuck up the joint and i'm
like they just never let me down
and it's beautiful because i i kind of i
confess i kind of use
i shouldn't confess this to his
colleague at the nfl network but i have
to
please i kind of use michael irvin to
sort of
sucker the cowboy fans into getting
hyped and excited
knowing the crash is coming
it's just a beautiful thing nothing
nothing pleases me
more than to see him and the rest of the
cowboy faithful miserable and i'm not
talking about the team
yes but the fans who i think they are
the most disgusting nauseating fan base
in history i can't stand a cowboy fan
they all make me sick including your guy
who i like but damn
he's a cowboy fan so i don't like him
right now i can't stand cowboy fans
and to watch michael irving get them
hyped yes
knowing they're going to fall and seeing
it having the force foresight to see it
yes
it's a beautiful thing when i know it's
coming and he's done set him up
it's beautiful well i i just know
stephen a in my household
yeah after what you refer to the
inevitable yeah
any game that the cowboys are expected
to win or the fan base hopes that they
win and then they do not
yeah all eyes in my household my wife
susie and i
are peeled on your to your twitter feed
that's right to see
yeah and it should that's right it's
coming the video's coming
it's beautiful it's beautiful man let me
tell you something right now i got so
much stuff planned for the cowboys this
year
i'm not gonna even reveal it i'm trying
to tell you now i'm gonna need
some permission from the nfl i'm gonna
need something i might even need
permission from jerry jo
because you know he as long as you talk
about the cowboys he don't care what
you're saying he's talking about his
cowboys you know jerry jones okay that's
my buddy right there his birthday is
october 13th
october 14th i love jerry jones i love
jerry jones he knows that
but if they let me the stuff that i got
planned for the cowboy
fans this year it'll be epic you are you
it's going to be epic there's production
value i mean what do we have i'm trying
to i'm trying to get
i i think it can be production valuable
i mean it could involve a cheerleader it
could involve the cheerleaders
okay it can involve police officers it
can involve a lot of different things
you understand and by the way i'm hoping
some of them are going to be live from
texas
because i wanted i want to be in the
stadium i actually
asked espn they said they said they're
not going to give us access to a t and t
stadium i said can we get the parking
lot that's all i need
i said they gotta come they gotta come
through there to get to
inside the stadium i said just let me
be outside the stadium it'll be
hilarious remember when they lost to the
rams
in the playoffs a couple of years ago in
los angeles that's right yes
what you didn't know is that i was
downtown at the jw marriott because
cowboy fans annoy me and they bugged me
and they always want pictures and they
they
call themselves heckling me even though
you only want four playoff games in 26
years
in 26 years but that's neither here nor
there that's near the end of them
so they come back right yes and the
cowboy fans
i'm literally in the lobby of the jw
marriott downtown of l.a live
yes greeting cowboy fence i thought hey
come on shake it off there you go
where are you don't you want a picture
don't you want a picture
oh you should have seen that they're
staying here and they were
running away from me they were running
away i said you asked anybody that was
there they were me i'm telling you if
somebody was there they'll remember i
was at i was in the lobby at the jw
marriott
greeting cowboy don't you want a picture
don't you want a picture with me oh they
were so disgusting so they should want
you
at the stadium because maybe just maybe
stephen a yeah
you you are there for the time that it
turns
maybe yes that you're there and the
cowboys actually yeah
well i mean it's awful listen man
listen to me
did you see michael irvin come on
stephen a's world he came on stephen
it's gonna be so fly and so far that's
what he was saying
talking smack and i'm like really you
saying that with a straight face
you know and then i talked to him about
a suit he's like what's the rule you
know what it is
it's i'm casket clean that's what he
said i've heard that one before i'm like
oh my lord where do you come up with
this stuff but he
really really believes it and he
convinces them
it's not going to happen rich i know
they gave daka's money
good for them to do that because it was
the right thing to do he deserved it yes
i know they got ezekiel
you see him you see him dipping a little
bit you understand what i'm saying
and i mean you know how they you know
what they say about run back everybody
everybody named derrick henry as you
well know
i mean ezekiel ellis gonna slip he gave
amari cooper 100 million i'm happy for
him he's a good brother i'm happy for
him
it's not going to work cd lamb you know
he could ball up it's not going to work
michael gallup the piece is there it's
not going to work somehow
some way something will go wrong you can
book it it's just don't even worry about
it
there's no worry about it well what
about what what do you think they should
do in the drift
tenth overall who cares
i mean clearly they did listen i
personally think certain
out of alabama isn't he's the big time
quarter you could use that to buffer
your defense because my god you're
ranked 31st
defensively couldn't stop the run to
save your life yes i mean they were
offered 28th defensively 31st against
the run neither here nor there the point
is is that they didn't have a defense
they couldn't stop a cold this is what
they are
this is what they are when their offense
is clicking defense is working when the
defense is clicking the office is
working when they're both clicking
something happens on special teams or
there's a coaching decision or a coach
you didn't get rid of
you kept kellen more around too long
just like you kept jason garrett around
too long
you shouldn't have gotten rid of rod
marinelli and richard
christopher shaw you shouldn't have
gotten rid of them there's always
something the only thing consistent
about the cowboys
is that they're gonna get their
headlines they're gonna get the headline
because jerry gonna get his heads lined
that's about it yeah outside of that
come on man come on now and me
personally it's a mistake to think that
i root for them to lose
quickly see i don't root for that
i want you to lose i don't want you to
stink in september
i want you to be good in october really
good in november
hell i don't even mind you winning on
thanksgiving i'm i feel better when you
lose
because i'm eating but i i don't mind
you winning on thanksgiving
but it's right around time when it's
christmas and also you see them
fluctuating they struggle
me personally i wish the dallas cowboys
went 16-0 in the regular season
and then john had to plummet ready to
play that would be my treat
when everybo i want there i want fans
expecting greatness
and then they fall apart right before
our very eyes just come crashing down
if you fall but you're already down it's
no fun in that i want you high so when
you fall it hurts
that's what i want for the cowboy thing
oh wow i i want everybody to
for the record yeah this answer came
from the question
of me asking if he missed the written
word
yeah yeah and then here comes
all of that all of that thank god but i
do mr written word a little bit
but i make up for with television plus
i'm gonna write my own book and stuff
like that so i'm i'm gonna do fine but i
would i would miss it a lot more if i
was writing about the cowboys because
i'd be able to write
and talk about them when was the first
time you met iverson
iverson um first time i met iverson was
uh when he showed
up in chicago to take his physical at
the nba pre-draft camp
uh in 1996 before he was ultimately
drafted number one overall
and that year i was named the backup
beat writer for the philadelphia 76ers
for the philadelphia inquirer right and
which was his rookie year
and then the very next year i was the
beat writer
for the philadelphia just as he arrived
really and just as he arrived and that's
how you know ultimately you know we
certainly had our ups and downs but
he's like a little brother to me we're
very tight we talk all the time
i love him dearly and um you know just
covering him every day
for the first 10 years of his career
obviously you cultivate a relationship
that
you know i mean i remember the players
used to accuse us of being a married
couple
because we go back and forth not talking
to each other is that right
he was mad at something that i said or i
was mad at his reaction to something
that i said and we'd go
weeks if not months at a time without
even talking and then
make up like you know it was just crazy
it was crazy but that's the relationship
he and i have had
he and i had uh in those in those parts
in those years when he was in
philadelphia right but obviously since
he's retired we've gotten a lot closer
well i mean i remember his practice rant
i was sitting there
getting ready to do the 2 a.m sports
center with stuart scott yeah
it happened just right around dinner
time yeah uh right around like 5
30 six o'clock blew up the whole six
o'clock eastern sports center
that was the entirety of that the thing
about it is that
you know a lot of people misconstrued
what was going on i knew what was going
on but it was still
obviously it was something that he he
regrets because that's infamous that
will never be forgotten
ever because that was one of the wildest
press conferences any of us had ever
seen
and his whole thing was that i'm a
league mvp i'm a scoring champion
i'm a year removed from taking us all
the way to the finals
shaq and kobe is what it took to stop us
or whatever
and we talking about trading me
because of practice man we talk about
the game not a game
not the game that i love and die for we
talking about
practice man let me and he and he meant
it from his soul like this
is why you're talking about letting me
go
because of practice and and and i think
the untold part about it all is that
larry brown who i also know and love
dearly and
and i consider to be maybe the greatest
coach that i've ever seen in my life
uh considering his knowledge of
basketball what he's taught
how many people that he's taught the
game to players and coaches
you know larry is is meticulous man and
he's about
doing things the right way playing the
right way
and if you don't believe that i remember
a game when allen iverson
came out and dropped 58
points on stevie franchise steve francis
and latino mobley and those boys houston
yeah and larry brown came to the post
game conference well you know there was
an open man over there and he missed him
he didn't give him the ball stephen and
here right here he could have done this
steven but he did i mean
that was larry brown and so you know it
it
it drove allen iverson crazy but that
was consistently larry brown if you were
a guy
that didn't put in the work when the
cameras were off and the crowd wasn't
in attendance if larry brown deemed you
as that kind of individual he didn't
want you
even if it was in the moment he might
change his mind tomorrow
because larry will love you today not
want you tomorrow and didn't want you
the next day after that
so he was temperamental like that but it
was all based off of you doing
what he felt you were supposed to be
doing to get better
every day that was a champion to larry
brown not somebody who just had the
gifts
but somebody who worked in their craft
and got better every day
and there were days he felt like allen
iverson didn't do that and that's where
it came from
but allen iverson was like it's practice
you're right we talking practice
stephen a smith here on the rich eisen
show steven a's world on espn plus first
take on espn every day among the many
uh items on this man's very busy full
plate what do you think of the current
sixers
that maybe they're the only team uh
outside of what milwaukee's got a shot
to derail the nets and what about their
their their
full they're full maybe don't want to
dismiss the miami heat because they were
in the finals last year but
i'll dismiss them only from the
standpoint that you're going you're
talking about kevin durant james harden
and and and kyrie irving now could they
give the sixers a run for their money
yes could they give milwaukee rough for
their money they just knocked the
milwaukee bucks out in five games in the
bubble
yes but brooklyn's a different animal
and because they're a different animal
the brooklyn nets can give up 129
20 points a night and not even blink
because they'll drop 130. this is who
they are they're that potent offensively
and when you look at the philadelphia
76ers clearly
doc rivers knows what he's doing he's
done an incredible job coaching them
joel embiid is a leading candidate for
league mvp honors when he's healthy he's
been playing like a monster
i think ben simmons is a leading
candidate for defensive player of the
year
so i'd give them a chance and i love the
shooters that they've surrounded them
with the problem is to me
you need ben simmons on the court
because he's such an incredible
basketball player
except for his perimeter shooting and
because he's no threat from the
perimeter
you're basically as a defense defending
514
unless you allow him to roam on the
baseline and make some things happen
because he's not a threat scoring from
the perimeter against milwaukee that
could work against miami that could work
against anybody
else it could work not against the
brooklyn nets in my opinion
you have to have all five guys on the
floor
that are a threat offensively because
they are just so
lethal themselves you know you're gonna
have to outscore them you're not beating
the brooklyn nets
by holding their offense in check it's
not gonna happen you have to be able to
score to beat them
and i think that with ben simmons not
shooting perimeter shots
that could come back to haunt them in
fairness to them doc rivers thinks i'm
wrong
he doesn't believe that ben simmons
needs to get a perimeter shot he and i
have talked about it
and i've nothing but profound respect
and admiration for doc rivers
but i looked him in his face and said
hell no you're wrong i don't believe
that
i think you need ben simmons to shoot
jump shots in order to at least be a
threat from the perimeter
milwaukee's a different animal because
jew holiday is there
you still kept middleton the greek
freak's got to get a better perimeter
shot
but also adding a guy like pj tucker
who's not only a defensive star
but a guy that you could place in any
corner left or right
and he'll bury those threes from there
that makes them an incredibly potent
threat
meanwhile out west you've got the lakers
flirting with a play-in game because of
the injuries that they've suffered
uh the clippers the pg-13 that the
clippers thought they were getting for
playoff p he's been
dynamite lately the jazz we know are
terrific jamal murray unfortunately is
out and then there's this
case of the suns going in this what do
you how do you how do you assess the
western conference as it sits right now
stevenson
my thing is it's all about the health of
anthony davis if anthony davis is 100
lakers are coming out of the western
conference i just think that he and
lebron james are two are the top five
players on the planet
and there's nothing you can do about
that i look at the utah jazz i give them
a lot of respect i think quinn schneider
and the staff have done an exceptional
job
but when you look at rudy gobert who
patrols the interior you look at royce
o'neill who patrols the perimeter from a
defensive perspective
their ability to shoot three-point shots
and i think donovan mitchell's a star
that makes them a threat we can't ignore
they're both top five defensively and
offensively
and obviously the road to the finals
might potentially have to go through
utah which is a tough place to play
and i think fans will be back come june
july
at least at 50 capacity if not better in
certain places
i think utah is one of those places so
as a result i think that will make it
incredibly tough
but ultimately anthony davis and lebron
james with the experience in the best
four
seven series i think they pulled that
out i think to me the team the watchers
the clippers and i've said this on many
occasions on first taking stephen a's
world and i'll say it again
paul george has to show up and play like
like the star that he is during the
regular season we get that
but we know we need to stop giving kawhi
leonard a pass
and here's what i mean by that he's a
two-time champion in the two-time nba
finals mvp
you won the mvp the first go-round of
san antonio in 2014 as a fourth option
you had tim duncan mounted you know be
tony parker all right so you fed off of
that and essentially
you you defended lebron and held them to
28 points per game i mean bravo
i mean that stopped the presses you held
them to 28 points a game okay
so i mean that even though he did shoot
about 37 against kawhi leonard fair
enough
but then you won then you won your
championship in toronto
well what happened in toronto you went
up against
golden state without k.d and oh by the
way clay got hurt in game two
was hobbled in games three and four came
back in game five
i'm sorry i'm sorry you know game came
back in game five as well
played kd comes back in game five goes
down for good
right his first game in that series and
then
klay thompson had 30 in the first two
and a half quarters
before he tore his acl i believe without
kd they would have beat toronto
if klay thompson was healthy the whole
series with steph curry
but then especially when the both of
them went down you lucked up that way
then fair enough you're a great top five
player
both ends of the floor koala is big time
we get all of that
you got the new balance commercial
you're driving a convertible
down to 405 or wherever the hell it was
you got the crown
dangling from the mirror you know it's a
new
day the new king has arrived you know
you you
metaphorically speaking that's what you
were saying the new king has arrived
because lebron hadn't made the playoffs
with the lakers in his first season
after he got injured and missed 17
straight games before missing
even more because the season was washed
and
you were feeling yourself and y'all up
3-1
on the denver nuggets and not only do
you let them come back from a 3-1
deficit
jamal murray drops 40
in a game seven you could play defense
paul george could play defense patrick
beverly can play defense and the brother
dropped
40. you were nowhere to be found in the
second half don't get me started with
the fourth quarter you would nowhere to
be found
to me kawhi leonard
should be on the clock yo bro what's up
we know you could play we know what you
could do
we know you the human cyborg no emotion
or whatever well damn it we got it for
you
where am i going to get my match up with
lebron and you that's what i want to see
right because even though basketball is
a team sport
we all know from the park to the court
period at some point in time that
one-on-one counter
happens and it's what matters to us
we want to see it i want to see it
lebron
kawad lakers clippers let's get it on
and so that's what i'm looking for for
this season because i do think that the
clippers
collectively are an incredibly
formidable threat to the los angeles
lakers let's see what happens in the
terms of the sun's
very gifted monty was doing a great
great job with randy is willie green and
his coaching staff chris paul is a
leader
and a should be an mvp candidate devin
booker's a star
we get all of that just young and i
think in the best 4-7 series
when you don't have that experience it
comes back to bite you i think they're a
piece away i think next year and beyond
we can look forward to the phoenix suns
this year they'll be in the playoffs
they could potentially make some noise
but i think they're on the outside
looking into the three teams i mentioned
previously stephen a
smith here on the rich eisen show
stephen a bringing is always the a game
as he does to steven a's world on espn
plus first take every single day
on espn uh before in the few minutes i
have left with you sir yeah
um i'd like to um give somebody
uh whose name was in another guest's
mouth
okay to respond okay uh lil rel howery
was on this program
recently you know little rel not only
from his work yeah
uh uh and in his conventional work but
also his work
during the all-star game in chicago
here's what lil rel howery
had to say when he was on this show just
a couple of weeks ago
lil rel did you are you telling me that
stephen a smith benched you
in the nba all-star celebrity game of
2020. so you're talking i remember
i remember him looking at all of us
because we we got destroyed he was like
yeah i made a mistake
i picked the wrong group of guys to do
this with
all guards is that what he said all
guards is what he said
like we have too small for them what you
smart for
they had like gifts for him and
everything he was like i'm good i'm gone
i'm going straight to the airport i'm
good i'm gone
okay so uh how accurate was that uh
telling of the
of the event stephen a 100 accurate
[Laughter]
look man
well first of all let me let me say this
i mean celebrity game espn
you know we we appreciate people who
participate you know and so they asked
me to be the celebrity coach and i'm
like cool i'm gonna have fun with this
or whatever
and i'm going up against my man my
brother michael wilbon yeah
um and i should have known it was fixed
because you see
you see you see michael wilbon is from
chicago
okay and so they gave him the bomb squad
okay they gave him the bomb squad
and i'm looking at my squad cause we
didn't pick you know the coaches we
didn't pick our squad okay so i get
there
and i'm seeing a bunch of people that's
coming up to my waist
well damn i'm only 6'1 this is a problem
this is a problem okay
and i mean asia will say that she could
ball she knows she wnba she was there
for me i'll love her forever because she
tried
and darius mars god god bless him you
know he's retired so i can't
knock him for the fact that you know he
was a little bit big but you know
but that's okay that's that's all right
that's all right hell i'm bigger
you know what i'm saying i love darius
you know and he was out there and he was
doing some good things
but little rel see it's it's and and
here's my problem
i'm a fan of his i'm a fan of his work i
think he does a great time
he does a great job on the shy and
various other uh
uh shows and movies that i've seen in
them i'm a huge fan little ralph
but i didn't ask for him on my screen
he asked he went on social media stephen
a
pick me pick me steven a i'm working on
my game
and i should have known when he had that
headband around him look at look at
look at like like martin when martin had
that episode with the cheap sneakers and
the cheap outfits or whatever
now this is what uh this dude right
there he was showing me videos of him
practicing
and he showed up on the court and i
watched him handling and doing workouts
and i know basketball so i'm like he
can't really handle the ride
all right okay steve be patient be
patient okay just try to be patient it's
all in fun
and then he dribbled the ball and
commented stripping himself
i said damn it all right i'm trying to
be patient but i'm already getting
annoyed
because he was talking he told me he
promised me at least 15.
i'm gonna give you 15 points right and
then
you showed the highlight when the
brother tripped over his own feet
and fell face first i mean he just went
tumbling down
yeah they didn't have the camera on me i
just turned away and just looked away
and i said oh my lord
and it was and we tried to be
competitive and we were in the first
half
before they pulled away i had no
shooters
i had no guards that could handle the
rock and i knew that fix was in
but i was specifically mad at him
because he
asked to be on the squad and
and and listen so you benched him you
died oh yeah
yeah i've been stuck i mean you pulled
them and you fetched them
not only did i pull them you know when
coaches put you on the bench and they
don't look at you they just continue
watching the game
that's what i did to him i just looked
and he walked by and i was like
you know i mean i i i could have
i it was like it was
it was really bad rich it was really
really bad and little rel listen
he's a phenomenal talent i love him i
wish him number the best
but he could never play for me again
ever
ever i never never
not basketball no ping pong it sounded
like that sure
you know but basketball my brother
he will never be on a team of mine again
it will not happen so it's 100 percent
true write that down
it's funny and he is right when he said
they were giving out gifts and stuff
like that i'm like i'm good i'm going to
the airport
i left i was so disgusted i went
straight to the airport
now don't get me wrong it was freezing
in chicago it was freezing so i was
anxious to get out of town anyway
right but after that performance i left
town
i left i went back to my hotel i grabbed
my luggage
and flew out that friday night yes i
flew back to new york that's how
disgusted i was i didn't even stay for
the friday night party
i was that disgusting i didn't deserve
it you can't have that on your record
you just can't you can it's not my
record performance it's fixed but i tell
you this much yes
i haven't played in a long time because
i had you know bad knees and
meniscus and cartilage tea and all that
stuff i've let
i've let espn know immediately after
that because you know common and people
like that common and a couple cats
and dudes that you know play other
sports not nba because i would never
disrespect nba players
like that and all of that other stuff
but if you're not a baller you can't
mess with me i don't give a damn how
long it's been since i played
so i went and got both knees operated on
okay and i had a torn rotator cuff that
i had never treated
i got that operated on this is all sense
that celebrity all-star game not this
year obviously
but when the fans come back and we have
a celebrity game by that time i'll be
54.
i'm playing i'm playing you're shooting
now
i'm suiting up i'm a busted living you
know what why not let's say you see a
bunch of people chirping
i see a bunch of them chirping but but
i'm not talking nba players now
i'm not on that level i'm not listening
even when i was young and healthy i
wasn't on that level
but but actors and people like little
rel and
talking just to be common comments
comments on michael boyle
talking because i love comment too a
comment i think common is a phenomenal
talent he's a good brother i love him
but i saw him on the court chirping at
me
you need to be out here really i'ma
remember that
i'm gonna remember that i'm gonna
remember that he's coming forward
i can't come and come doctors tell me i
should be healthy
i should be ready to go okay obviously
health permitted but i assure you
if i'm healthy i will play and i'm and
when and i'm gonna remember
all of the cats that were chirping on
michael wilbon squad
and i hope michael wilbon called as
coaching them again because it was fixed
espn i'm accusing my own employees
he left me and fixed the game for
michael wilbon
them in concert with the nba had rigged
it
for michael wilbon to win in his
hometown i always tell him the fix was
in
i was set up that you have that go for
it we have been hoodwinked
bamboozled left astray and
got out the seat that's right
that's right that's right i'm gonna get
them all
i'm gonna get them all
[Applause]
oh man stephen a you are the best thank
you for doing this thank you
you are truly a treasure i'm thrilled
i'm able to call you a friend and have
you we go back we go back years
and and the the work that i do at espn
is people like yourself and dan patrick
and the keith olbermanns chris bermans
and
of course the late great stuart scott
your buddy of mine
loved them dearly john saunders all of
y'all paved the way for people like
myself to be in the position that i'm in
and i know you do great
work here you do great work on the nfl
network but you did so much great work
for espn over the years all of us love
you thank you and
and that's why i'm here because we love
you man and i'm honored to be here thank
you
i frequently think sometimes what would
stewart think about stuff that's going
on in the sports world
yeah well he'd be at the forefront doing
his thing
and and doing it well and great great
one of the phenomenal talents that ever
existed in this industry yeah
good man we miss him me too thanks for
doing this by the way
i think what you know not to tell you
how to run your business maybe you do
get
common and everybody that chirped at you
on stephen a's world and have it out oh
no no
i think once i know i'm gonna play right
i'm gonna invite them
on just to tell them what's coming
just to tell them what's coming that's
content just to tell them what's coming
i'm coming for it and by the way yes
continue the great job with you
the nfl network on your show but y'all
got to do something about michael
irvin's suits i mean you
kirk coach mariucci uh mooch i mean and
you know mooch and i know each other
because i'm good friends with
tom izzo and that's his buddy right here
that's his guy best man big weddings
who swears by mariucci that's good
enough for me because i love izzo but
right
i mean y'all could do something about
michael irvin's wardrobe
y'all do have impact i mean come on
y'all
help the brother out he needs it you
know what stephen a
i think it's something again that is
just
the phrase it is what it is and that's
about it why are y'all allowing him to
lie about his afro we all know that's a
toupee
why are y'all allowing that too why
y'all allowing michael irvin to get away
with that i mean i can use it
i could use it myself he gonna sit up go
like his prime real estate of his prime
real estate
that's what he says i'm like really
that's a toupee i'm
telling you man that's a toupee i'll
tell you we're gonna find out about i
don't know when
but we're going to find out that michael
irvin was wearing the toupee
we're going to find it out that's called
a mic drop everybody steven a smith
check out steven a's world every day uh
four days a week on espn plus and first
take every single day good to see you
good to see
you you're the man stephen h smith
everybody hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here